[MUSIC PLAYING]
URBAN: I'm Glen Urban,
Dean of the MIT Sloan
School of Management.
And it's my privilege
to welcome you
to this fifth lecture
in our industry leaders
in technology management series.
This is co-sponsored by
the School of Management
and the School of Engineering.
We bring to campus here
the world's leading CEOs
to give us their
guidance and wisdom.
You may have been here last
week when Jack Smith was here
from GM.
You probably also remember
our earlier speakers
Alex Troutman from Ford and
Gordon Binder from Amgen.
Today it gives me great
pleasure to introduce
an equally eminent
speaker, Dr. Andy
Grove, who is the president
and CEO of Intel Corporation.
Dr. Grove's life really
shows graphically
the opportunities in America.
He came here from Hungary in
1957, enrolled in City College
and got a bachelor's degree in
chemical engineering in 1960.
Went on to get a PhD the
University of California
in 1963.
And in 1968, teamed up with
Gordon Moore and Bob Noyce,
then at Fairchild
Semiconductor, and they
formed some little
startup company called
Intel, which has been the
home for Andy for 30 years,
at this point.
Tremendous career.
A tremendous company.
He's been one of
the driving forces
behind making this successful.
You may recall that
five years ago,
or so, various people
were predicting
that the US IC industry
would be out of business.
Well, in the last years, 1990
to 95, under Andy's leadership
the sales at Intel have gone
from $4 billion to $16 billion,
the profits from $650
million to $3.5 billion,
and the stock price on
average from $10 to over $65.
So it's hard to find a
more successful track
record for company leadership.
Dr. Grove is going
to speak to us today
on exploiting the crisis points
challenging every company
and career.
And you don't have to
take too many notes
because he's just
written a new book that
describes many of these ideas.
Only the paranoid survive.
And if you happen to see
the latest Forbes magazine,
Forbes says that,
"this is probably
the best book written on
business by a business person
since Alfred Sloan's My
Years at General Motors."
So, welcome home and you're
in good company here.
Please welcome me in joining
with Dr. Grove for this
[INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
GROVE: First of all,
is the mic working?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GROVE: Good.
What I would like to
do is, first of all
stay nearby here if that's
OK with your protocol.
And use this overhead
projector to walk you
through some of the
observations that
are in fact, the
kernel of that book,
and have been based on my
experience and laboratory
tested, beta tested if you wish,
on the competitive business
school whose name
shall remain unnamed.
But it's on the west
coast near where I live.
[LAUGHTER]
How many of you are business
school students here?
How many are engineers?
Now, how many of you are
business school students who--
how many of you have
an undergraduate degree
in engineering?
That's pretty good.
OK.
The reason I'm
asking is because I
want to tell you what the
real title of this book
was intended to be, and I
didn't want to miss my mark.
I wanted to call this book,
strategic inflection points.
And it's meant for
general purpose audiences,
and my publisher
wouldn't hear of it.
And to make a long story
short, a long and short of it,
it got a catchier title.
But that is what
the book is about.
Strategic inflection
point is my way
of visualizing and describing
a fundamental change
in the well-being of a business.
Fundamental change in the
well-being of an industry.
It's a curve more or less going
like this, which I don't know,
can the overflow
people see this?
There is a video set up for it?
OK.
The hardest time we
all have at business
is not a break point in
a curve, if the curve
represents the well-being
of the flow of a business.
It is exactly at
that subtle point
where the curvature
changes, we're
going from convex to concave,
or the other way around.
I never could figure that out.
And it's exactly at that point
that the nature of the business
around us is changing.
And it's changing
in a subtle way,
but changing in a profound
and lasting fashion.
And those people
in a business who
do not make the adjustment
to the new curvature
go into decline.
That's kind of the
graphical representation
of what I'm talking about.
And another way
to look at this is
to look at the conditions under
which the businesses undergo,
or businesses in general,
undergo strategic inflection
points.
And I trust the business
school students among you
have studied, in
one form or another,
camouflaged as it
might have been,
Porter's competitive
strategy concept.
Probably called five
forces diagram or something
to take the brand name of it.
Is that right?
Yes.
OK.
That's what they do at
the other named school.
Anyway.
Porter made a real contribution
by basically graphically
depicting competitive forces.
And I redrew it a little
bit because I amended it
with another contribution
that actually
came from a couple of
professors, one at Harvard one
at Yale.
The six forces to
broaden it, that affect
a business: customers
power, competitive forces,
intra-industry competitive
forces, supplier power, forces
of substitution, and adding
to that complementors.
People who are crucial in
adding additional value
to the value of the
product in question.
Easiest way to look at it,
Microsoft is our complementor.
Microsoft software makes Intel
microprocessors more valuable.
Intel is Microsoft's
complementor.
Microsoft software, without
Intel microprocessors,
would clearly not be as
valuable as it is with.
This is sort of the general
analysis of describing
how a business operates
and this is not
what I was going to talk about.
What we are going
to look at and what
we are going to
examine here is what
happens when one of those forces
becomes very, very much larger
than the others.
And I want to call it an order
of magnitude in order to--
order of magnitude
is not exactly
a trade publication term.
I called it a 10x force.
A 10 for 10 force, 10
times increase relative
to the other forces.
What happens when
there is such, one
of the forces that determine
the well-being of a business
really grows out
of bound and so big
that it can distort the picture.
And what tends to
happen at times
like that is that the very
nature of the industry changes.
Not the business, not the
competitive well-being
of the business alone, but the
whole business model changes.
And I give you an
example that comes
right from our own
industry on this one.
And on the left
of the diagram you
would have maybe the business
model of the computing industry
as it used to be performed
in the '60s, '70s, '80s.
Computers were sold as
vertically integrated devices,
proprietary platforms,
proprietary operating systems,
applications developed for that
propriety operating system,
and a whole stack of things
sold by Salesforce that
was unique to that enterprise.
Then came the personal
computer, which
was in fact a genuine almost
quantitatively correctly
describable 10x force in
that its cost effectiveness
relative to mainframes
or mini computers
was about 10-fold right
from the inception on.
And it was clearly a toy.
And it was clearly unreliable.
And it couldn't do
the software that
was pertinent to
business processes.
But it was so cost
effective that
is represented a 10x force.
And in front of our
eyes in the course
of the decade of the
'80s, the entire structure
of the industry changed from
the vertical towers of computer
products competing
with each other
to a completely horizontal
industry in which
microprocessors compete
with other microprocessors,
operating systems compete
with other operating systems,
applications
software in a packet
form like a bunch
of commodity goods,
like a bunch of
detergents, compete
for deck shelf space with
other application software.
And direct sales goes out
as a means of distribution.
Distribution becomes
all indirect.
In terms of your experience
it's very difficult
to imagine how ridiculous
the whole concept of selling
computers through a
telephone and through mail
would have sounded
to somebody who
was steeped in the computer
industry of the left side
of the diagram.
I mean it was, it
wasn't even laughable.
People wouldn't even
engage that idea.
So that's how much it changed.
So the business model
changed under this part
of this 10x force
from a particular way
of doing computing to a
completely different view
in computing.
And the time period that I'm
interested in talking about,
and I'm interested
in considering,
is what happens in between
those two by two diagrams.
I call it the valley of death.
That's one way to describe it.
Another way to describe
it is, picture some kind
of a graphical
figure being morphed
into another graphical figure.
A phase being morphed
into another phase.
And it's in-between when
the bits are all distorted
and all jumbled up, when you
can't make heads and tails out
of the diagram, there's
no shape to things.
That is when managing
an enterprise,
and for that matter
managing a career,
are the trickiest tasks.
And that's what we
are talking about.
Let me give you a couple
more examples to bring
some reality to this.
And the 10x force can
come in a variety of ways.
I described in the case
of the computer industry,
it came through technology.
Higher power technology
brought a great deal
of cost effectiveness.
In the case of the
Porter diagram,
it caused substitution
in a very large scale.
It can come in
various other ways.
If you are a retailer in
a small or medium town
someplace in America, the
strategic inflection point
arrives in the form of
a bunch of surveyors
who come and start surveying
the property in one
of the most highly traveled
intersections in town.
And then a sign goes up,
future home of Walmart.
Now you say, what's
the difference?
There never was just one
retail store in this town.
There were always
a bunch of them.
Any owner of a
retail store would
say I always had competition.
I have competition now.
So one more, what the
hell is the difference?
And this is the 10x force.
Walmart is not just
one more competitor.
It is the largest retailer
in the world tuned, tuned,
genetically tuned, to
operate at thin margins, very
high volumes, using information
technology, satellite
technologies, transportation
technologies, all fine tuned
to do that to a precision.
That small town retailer
cannot conduct their business,
its business, in the same
fashion just thinking that
it's another competitor, or else
they're going to go downhill
on that curve.
So that's the example
of a competitive force
that would be a 10x force.
Sometimes these forces come in
the form of regulatory changes.
An example of that is
what happened in 1984
when in the form of the
modified final judgment,
judge brought about the
deregulation of a many decade
old, countrywide monopoly that
was the AT&T of that time.
And the repercussions of that
change have been immense.
And it impacted the
well-being of not one company,
but a lot of companies.
They certainly impacted
the well-being of AT&T,
old and new.
Impacted the well-being
of MCI, Sprint,
and untold alternative
service providers.
Impacted the well-being of the
regional operating companies.
Impacted the well-being
of customers.
And most importantly,
impacted the well-being
of probably 150,000 employees
of the old AT&T, who
are no longer working for
any telephone company.
So this is not a change.
This is a cataclysmic change.
It was a strategic
inflection point.
And very few people
realized at the time,
I was around at the time,
I was calling on AT&T
because it's one
of our customers.
They were confused.
It was like the bits in the
middle of the morphing process.
They didn't know what
was going to happen.
But none of them could
foresee the extent
it was going to change
their well-being
and their business processes.
We talked about the
computer industry.
And the one other thing
that I want to say
is, which we are in the
middle of, the internet.
You know, you pick up any
trade magazine, any newspaper,
any anything, I mean
the internet is being
beaten to death in the press.
But the larger picture is that
there is a phenomenon coming
here that is likely to
affect not just one industry,
like all of these examples have,
but half a dozen industries.
Industries that don't
even know that this--
what, how does
packet switching have
to do with the media industry?
What the hell does
the internet has
to do with the entertainment
industry in Hollywood?
What does it have to do
with the service industries?
And yet, enormous
industries that
have kind of minded
their own business,
never even until a few years
ago even have heard the phrase,
will be morphed.
Will be restructured.
Will have to undergo over
the next several years
a valley of death type
of transformation.
Now exactly how
will that shape up?
I don't know.
In 10 years I could come
back if your interested,
and I'll tell you
exactly how it happened.
Just like I can't tell you
about the computer industry.
But right now, it's a bunch
of bits in a confused fashion,
and we are just entering
the valley of death.
It is very confusing
in the middle of it.
That's not unusual.
That is what it's like because
the new business model doesn't
take shape very clearly.
And a lot of people
have different ideas
on how it's going to be.
And which is why, of course,
all the newspapers are
filled with very
superficial speculation
on the shape of the future.
So to sum this, the
strategic inflection point
happens when there's
a major change
in the competitive environment.
It can be technological,
regulation, 10x competition
force.
And a key element is
that it is very often,
and I don't know if
always, because I haven't
made an exhaustive study of it.
But very often, the
first signs of it,
the first recognition
of it, does not
come from senior
management, people like me.
But come from people who
are in the front lines
of the key activities
of the corporation.
Salesforce is very
likely to realize
changing customer preferences
much before sales management
is.
Now, do they understand that
it's a change of customer
preferences?
No, they just understand
something that used to work
doesn't work anymore.
Then they go home
and tell that story.
And they can't make a
coherent story out of it.
So they get thrown out.
Go away.
Just work harder.
And the fact of the matter
is something changed in them.
And because it is so murky,
they can't articulate the story.
And the internet is
a perfect example.
The people who
understood those things,
that were people who were
users of the internet.
But they didn't understand
how big it was going to be.
Or they understood that their
little world was suddenly
intruded by a bunch of
people who had no business
being on the internet.
And I see a number
of nodding heads.
And those people
probably realize
that something is
changing in the aggregate
a long time before most
people in corporate
may even had a whiff of it.
What is going to happen
when that happens
is that individuals
like that are
going to start turning
into being Cassandras.
And because mostly this
change is not for the better.
Mostly the change is something
that worked, doesn't work.
And our products are no
longer [INAUDIBLE] at them.
In our case, when Intel was a
semiconductor memory company.
We pioneered
semiconductor memories.
We were the leaders in
In the mid '80s, the Japanese
came and became a 10x force
for us in
semiconductor memories.
And one of the first
signs as I look back,
I didn't look at it at
that time as a sign.
I looked at it as a
whining sales force.
But one of the first
signs that I look back
that should have tipped
us off was our sales force
in Japan saying that
the customers are not
as respectful of them
as they used to be.
And that was such a telling
story in retrospect.
If I look back on
the curve, that's
when the curve was beginning
to enter into the inflection
point.
There weren't because they knew
that their internal capability,
the customer's internal
capability, the semiconductor
sister division was going
to run circles around us.
They knew that.
And that attitude changed
toward our sales force.
Or sales force told us.
Us, being management,
ignored it.
We ignored it.
When they showed up
here, we ignored it
as we were starting
to lose market share.
And the people in our company
who realized what was going on
was our group of
production planners
who started adjusting
our factory loading away
from memories, toward
microprocessors.
Why?
Because we had better
business opportunities
in microprocessors.
We made more money
microprocessors.
So we're not making a big
fanfare [INAUDIBLE] lots
by [INAUDIBLE] lots.
They just move the
production lots
from memories to
microprocessors.
So by the time those of us
who ran the company started
facing up to that, that our core
business, which were memories,
was going away, because of
these incremental our actions
of our finance people,
and production planners,
and lower level management,
we were much less exposed
to the memory business.
We had gradually rationalize
our factory infrastructure
so that we still
have to cut back.
We still have to
shut down factories,
but much less than had these
Cassandras not taking matters
into their own hands.
So spontaneous actions through
front line or lower level
employees who are much
closer to the action
is a very key element in causing
adjustment in the business
structure of a company.
That's a key element.
What tends to happen is when--
I'm sorry, I took
this off too early.
What tends to happen is there
is, at times like these,
there's a growing divergence.
A dissonance between
the actions of people
who are close to the actions
and the comprehension
and statements of senior
management, like myself.
I call that strategic dissonance
because a corporation,
in its daily
action, is beginning
to do something deviant from
the stated mission, values,
competencies, that
continues to get articulated
in the management.
So one of the big telltale
signs in a business that it
is struggling with a
strategic inflection point
is this growing and
seemingly irreconcilable
difference between
what the company does
and what the company says
it's supposed to be doing.
It's not because people
involved are dumb, or phony,
or hypocritical, or
anything like that,
but because senior
management was
responsible for
the articulation.
It was giving the interview
that the employees
read in the newspaper.
Doesn't know it yet.
The employees know
it's not real.
The senior management
doesn't know it's real.
That's a terribly strong sign.
And I'm not going to
name names because it
gets you a little
closer to present time.
But there's very
relevant examples
of that taking place in the
recent past in the information
technology industries.
To cope with it, to
cope with this process
requires fundamental changes
in your business outlook.
Fundamental changes
in the definition
of what your business
is and what it might be.
Fundamental changes in the core
competencies, the capabilities,
of the corporation.
If you've been doing this all
along, like in Intel's case.
We had been in the
microprocessor business
for 10 years before
this change occurred.
We had a lot of capabilities.
We had the option of abandoning
our traditional business
and emphasizing an
emerging business.
If we didn't, we would have been
up the creek without a paddle.
It is very important,
for that reason alone,
to cultivate additional
and corollary supporting
competencies so that
when shifts take place,
you've got places to shift to.
More about that
in a few minutes.
A key issue that we
need to deal with
is organizations,
corporations, individuals
dealing with the carriers.
Governments are constantly
surrounded by indications
of monumental changes.
And one of the--
they are not all real things.
For every real inflection
point causing change
that you have to deal
with there are 10 items
that are really not
much more than noise
when you look back
retrospectively.
So, how do you tell
one from the other?
And I wish I was able to give
you a little diskette that you
run this program and fill in
the blanks and it will tell you.
I can't.
I have looked at and thought
through a variety of examples
of this.
And some examples may mean
something to some of you.
Ten, twelve years ago,
there was a big raging trend
toward X-ray lithography
in our industry.
And particularly our
Japanese competitors
were investing very
heavily into it.
And some Americans felt that
unless we made that change
in the language that
I'm using today,
we're going to go down
the hill and decline
in a strategic inflection point.
We analyzed this seven
ways through Sunday
and decided it was
really a spurious noise.
Again, using today's language.
And we turned out to be right.
X-ray lithography in the last
10 years hasn't gone anywhere.
Visible light and ultraviolet
light, lithography,
doesn't matter what, the
conventional techniques
could be extended much more.
And we were right.
And an interesting
question, does that
mean that X-ray lithography
will never go anywhere?
It doesn't.
X-ray lithography
as a threat may
have been a bit of noise
ten, twelve years ago.
And may become a strategic
inflection point a year
from now, five years from
now, ten years from now.
So there is not a general
deal that a certain phenomenon
is right or wrong.
It is or is not a
strategic inflection point.
It is in the context
of the time, context
of the state of the
business, the context
of the evolution
of the technology.
Another example that
I want to touch on
is risk technology,
as in microprocessors.
That was a late '80s phenomenon
and it was taken very seriously
by a lot of players as a
10x force, a 10x better
way of building
microprocessors that
could in fact uproot the
structure of the business
and create a lot of trouble for
established players like Intel.
And in fact, a lot
of people at Intel
thought that might be the case.
So we had enormous
raging debate.
And a major
development, to hedge
our bets of a risk
processor whose advocates
and whose designers
believed it was a 10x force.
And we continue to pursue our
regular standard architecture,
whose designers and
developers thought it wasn't.
So this debate took place
very heavily internally.
And it was a very
expensive proposition
both in terms of double
investment streams
and in terms of
the wear and tear
on people in our management,
including myself,
because I didn't understand the
issues involved here at all.
This was way outside of
my technical competence.
And I had to rely on the advice
of people, who all of a sudden
barely said good
morning to each other.
They were so emotional
on the subject.
Now, we pursued this parallel
development up to a point,
and then eventually
out of all this debate,
and debate is in fact one of the
most important ways of dealing
with this thing, we
came to the conclusion
it was not a strategic
inflection point.
That more, almost literally,
it was not a 10x improvement,
it was a 2 to 3x improvement.
And is likely to be less
and less as time goes on.
Turns out, again in the
time frame we were right.
But before you were
right, half the people
who were involved in the risk
process have left the company.
The relationships that were
torn up, for the largest part,
never were healed.
So these things are not
fun and easy processes.
Even inside a company.
Even among people who
know each other well.
I'm going to switch to
a different subject,
so we'll have opportunity
to do questions.
Which is, this is what I dealt
with is methods of recognition
is a phenomenon of strategic
inflection point or not.
But let's suppose we
are past that stage.
That we are entering a
strategic inflection point.
Dean Urban.
Where are you?
I see you.
Is it proper for a lecturer
to remove his jacket?
Thank you.
URBAN: The audience [INAUDIBLE]
GROVE: No, I'm not going to
get that naked in a school.
So, you are in one of them.
You are in that valley of
the Death, Valley of death.
And the subject I want
to talk for a few minutes
is what are some
of the techniques
that you can do
to get through it.
And the best way
to look at that is,
this process has two stages.
The first half and
the second half.
The first half, is
again keep in mind
this morphing metaphor,
as you enter it
from an orderly to a
disorderly state of affairs.
From a phase that you recognize
to a bunch of mixed up bits.
And things are
terribly confusing.
The people, the
Cassandras that come in
bring you the stories
from the field.
From the [INAUDIBLE]
don't make any sense.
You don't feel
comfortable anymore.
So what you need to do is
let loose of the reins of it.
Let chaos reign in your
organization about it.
Let experimentation take place.
Now, the natural state of
organizations is chaos.
That applies to
all organizations.
It's a corollary of the
second law of thermodynamics.
So ordinarily
management is there
to fight the dispersion of
the forces in the company
and bring some
cohesion in there.
So this is not a natural
act for management,
letting chaos reign.
Particularly not a natural
act when management
is getting a little
uncomfortable about the state
of the business.
And I'm sitting there
watching these things.
I'm not that comfortable.
So what is my
reaction going to be?
I want to pull in the
reins, not let go.
And in reality, in this
stage, we have to constantly,
we have to discipline
ourselves to letting things go.
Because the only way we
are going to put some shape
and certainty into this
ambiguity in our business model
is to let a bunch
of things go on
and to watch them like a hawk.
Now, I'm not going to
do the experiments.
But I can very easily
watch all those experiments
and see which one gets
traction and which one--
I mean, I don't actually
mean technical experiments,
although sometimes that might
be the answer to the question.
But funding development
programs that
are mutually contradictory.
And you're going to get a lot
of stuff, backtalk, on this one.
How can you give money for this
and not give money for that?
And you are all confused.
You have your head up in the
wrong place, et cetera, et
cetera et cetera.
But you have to bear with
that because at this point
you simply are not in
a position to know.
So this is the phase when
I say let chaos reign.
Do a lot of experimentation.
And one, I'm not covering
every item on this force so
try not to stay synchronous
with the fall there.
But what is extremely
important, ideally,
is to start doing this
experimentation at a time
when your existing
business is strong.
It provides a protective
bubble over the totality
of your business.
Now this is so damn
logical it's not funny.
The time to start playing
with new things, a time
to start experimenting,
the time to start investing
in those new things, to
develop those competencies,
is when your core
business is wrong.
And what is real life?
Real life is I want to do that.
I'm going go to my best guy
here and say, OK, you're
going to go on this
emerging stuff.
And every general manager
is going to jump on me,
how can you pull him
out of the business that
pays all of our salaries?
He says, OK, no, no,
no, I was kidding.
I was kidding.
It was a bad idea.
Bad idea.
Let me take him.
And he came up way below him,
the other guy in the ranking.
Let him do the new business.
And he is really not very good.
We are only keeping him
for tradition's sake.
Nothing personal.
Then we put him on the new area.
And guess what, the new area
is not going to succeed.
Now, is it not going to
succeed because it was
a bad idea in the first place?
Or is it not going to succeed
because we put our second class
people on developing it?
That's how it goes in real life.
And you know, on the other hand
I keep coming back to that,
management is not--
you don't get drafted
to be a manager.
You enlist to be a manager.
You like all the
various elements of it.
One flip side of it is
you have to do things
that require self-discipline.
It's kind of like dieting and
exercise and a bunch of stuff
that you don't
necessarily want to do,
but you do because
they're good for you.
Making choices like
that, you've got
to do because it comes
with the territory.
Having said that,
very few people
use the business bubble
to make their choices.
They hang onto the
business bubble.
They want to extend it.
And they under invest in the
experimentation with the result
that when things happen,
their wrong people
are in the wrong territory.
I'm not talking about them.
I'm talking about me.
Literally.
In that situation when
we were in the DRAM
business and the
production planners
very cleverly over
some period of time
got us out of DRAM
production and ramped up
microprocessor production.
That was good because
the production planners
could do it.
But only senior
management could assign
development resources,
development laboratories,
to do certain lines of work.
So our best
laboratory was working
on what, microprocessors?
No, DRAMs.
And they were doing
a phenomenal job.
They were developing the
world's first seamless
DRAM faster than anybody
else was, including
the Japanese manufacturers.
And it was completely
useless because we
didn't have any factories in
the works to produce them.
We didn't have
any real intention
to put them into production.
In the meanwhile
the product that we
were starving from development
resources for exactly
the little exercise
that I played out,
was the second
generation version
of the 386, which happened
to be the stuff that
led to those spectacular results
that Dean Urban described
in the introduction.
So you know, you don't have to
go very far to see examples.
And we corrected it.
But we corrected it,
kind of my universe
concept of my own
career, every decision
that I've ever ended up
making that turned out
to be a right decision, I made
it a minimum of a year late.
This one we probably made
more like a year and a half
to two years late.
We took that theme and put them
on the second generation 386.
And we did and fortunately
we were still ahead
of the competition so
that we did OK with it.
But in a more demanding
business environment,
it would have been
too little too late.
Then comes the second phase.
The morphing process continues,
the bits are beginning to gel,
and you begin to see the
outlines of the new picture.
And at this point,
now you can do what
you have been wanting to do.
Pull in the reins.
At this point, it's time to take
stock of those experimentation
and make order and decide
what we are going to do
is this and that.
And interestingly,
by now your people
may have gotten used to chaos,
and the kind of like chaos.
Like I tell you,
organizations like chaos.
So this is not exactly a
highly popular act either
at the time it comes.
The only difference is that if
you are like most companies,
that you're not doing this in
the middle of a benign business
bubble, but you are doing
it where you are in trouble.
People will support
harsh actions
because they want leadership
to drag them out of the mess
that they are in.
The catch is, you
know, the reason
I have two hands is so
I can do on the one hand
on the other hand, constantly.
On the other hand
on this one, is
that you, the leader
of that organization,
or you, the leader of your
own career, are not that sure.
You're beginning to see that
picture gel as you're moving
across the morphing process.
But you're not very sure.
But you have to
act as if you were.
So you have to, you're
pulling the reins
and commit yourself
to of course of action
at a time when your
knowledge and your certainty
lags way behind where you are.
It's a very difficult process.
A very imperfect process.
It's a process that is
fraught with dangers
because by committing
yourself to that,
you're committing
yourself wrong.
You are sunk.
But, if you don't commit
yourself you are sunk for sure.
Because in most of
these situations
you are living in a
competitive environment
where there's very little
tolerance for error.
But if you're not
committing yourself,
you're not going
to commit an error,
you simply are giving
time to your competition.
And there's kind of a
universal law in business.
The only thing there
is in business is time.
You give time to somebody else,
you take it away from yourself.
That's all you got.
So hesitation transfers
time to your competition.
And that time, it
never will come back.
So the earliest moment
make a work up your courage
to commit yourself to
the reigning in the chaos
is the time to act.
I've talked about a
bunch of things here,
and some of those things have
a very psychobabbly tone to it.
And that's how it is.
Managers are people.
Their employees are people.
And work, and living, and their
careers, and their long term
success is very
important to each
of these individuals involved.
So when things go bad you're
going through the same stages
as you go through in
personal catastrophes.
You have to go through the
usual stages of denial,
which is very, very strong.
That is why you want to
shoot the Cassandras,
because your denial of this
new thing that you don't want
to deal with, that you
don't know how to deal with,
is so strong.
You work your way
through escapism.
I have this deep
seeded suspicion
that the predominant
reason people engage
in big time acquisitions
is to escape
from dealing with a
strategic inflection
point in their own business.
In their own core business.
Because nothing is as seductive
as teeing up and flying
from one place to the other.
Staying up all night with your
lawyers and your investment
bankers and calling
a press conference
and being on the front page
of the newspaper the next day.
How does that compare
with figuring out
which factory to shut down?
I mean, which one
would you rather do?
And it is so tempting to immerse
yourself into stuff like that
as a legitimate escape.
Not an escape like I go on the
golf course or go on a safari
to Africa, but a
legitimate escape.
I'm working real
hard to do that.
I don't know if this is true.
I don't know how to study it.
But I do have that suspicion.
But when you get out of this,
and the escape didn't work,
you move on to the acceptance
and pertinent action.
And the question here is,
do you do it in time enough,
or do you wait until you have
frittered away your resources?
And to a very large
extent, this is
an issue of human makeup
as much as anything else.
The last point I want to make,
everything I have said here
applies to your careers.
And I'm not talking to you as
a bunch of CEOs of corporations
now.
I'm talking to you
as a bunch of CEOs
of your own little business.
Starts at the top of your
head and ends at your toes.
That's your corporations.
You've been investing in it.
Heaven knows, I don't know.
Probably $30,000 a year.
Whatever this
outfit charges here.
And before, and you're
going to continue too.
And it's yours to manage.
And we are in a
very different era
than my generation
managed career was in.
My generation could
assume that when
we went to work
for an enterprise,
that enterprise could provide
us with a measure of stability
that would guide us through,
in a very smooth fashion,
the inflection point
that always came.
That's not new.
It was always around.
Enterprises are now going
through inflection points
of their own that doesn't
guarantee their own survival.
So enterprises are
far more preoccupied
with their own survival
today than they
were a generation ago.
And therefore, they are less
able physically less able
and emotionally and interest
wise and concentration
wise, less able to
deal with the survival
of the many little careers,
the many little businesses
that their employees represent.
This subtle favorite
cliches of business life
today make this problem worse.
We love globalization.
Globalization means that
the world is our oyster.
We can sell a product
everywhere from here to Jindong.
Globalization also means that
every person, every working
person of the same general
training, same general business
occupation in the world
competes with you.
That they work for companies
that compete for your company.
In a brief period of 30 years,
from the '60s to the '90s,
the United States
in the aggregate
has gone from an almost
dominant industrial power
to one of the leading
industrial powers.
If you look at that
as a market analysis,
being a dominant
industrial power,
a dominant power
in your industry
versus being one of the
contenders back into the Porter
model dealing with substitution,
dealing with new entrants,
dealing with intense
intra-industry rivalry, life
has gotten a lot tougher for
the United States economy.
Consequently, life has
gotten a lot tougher
for companies that make up
the United States economy.
Consequently, those companies
are much less able to.
It's not that they became venal,
not that they became evil.
They're simply less
able to provide
this style of career development
and career maintenance
that they used to do it.
Now if they don't do it,
who's going to do it?
And I'm advocating
basically doing
the same concept of
strategic analysis
and apply it to your career.
And foremost among those is
watch for strategic inflection
points.
Work on separating the
signal from the noise.
And we complete, conclude
that it's signal.
Experiment first and
then pull in the reins
and commit yourself.
And discipline
yourself to overcome
the denial and the various
other human foibles that
will come in the way
in your own career,
as well as in your business.
So, that's all I have,
and I will take questions
from both here and outside.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: How does Intel become
equally qualified competitors,
such as Texas Instruments
who produces--
How does Intel keep a company
like Texas Instruments, who
also produces a very
high quality chip,
from taking market share?
GROVE: How does Intel
keep competitors,
like Texas Instruments who also
produce high quality chips,
from taking market share?
You know, back in the mid '80s
when we almost died and went
through our strategic inflection
point and we came out of it,
we came out of it with a very
strong and very controversial
then, not so
controversial today.
Like I said, all
of these stories
are a lot easier, a lot
clearer 10 years later.
Then, very controversial
decision, that we
will focus on microprocessors.
First, second, and third.
We will put him, I was pointing
at you, a microprocessor
and everybody else we
got to put the best
development on microprocessors.
And we're going to invest in the
best microprocessor factories,
in the best
microprocessor design
tools, and this worked for us.
And over time, our
expertise has led
to reinforcing a positive
feedback, if you wish.
The better we became, the more
we are able to attract the best
people, the more we are able
to get the attention of people,
other companies, who design
development tools that are
tuned more for our needs
than for somebody else's.
So, it has become easier.
And we have not
merged with anyone.
We have not bought
a Hollywood studio.
We have not done
any of these things.
We are a very, very
maniacally focused company
on microprocessors.
That's all.
No more to it.
We work pretty hard because kind
of, like the phrase suggests,
we are a pretty
paranoid company.
We are worried about not any
one of them in particular,
but in the aggregate
we like our business.
It's a good business
and we intend
to sell our product
to every socket.
And we pursue it like we were a
startup fighting for our life.
But that's an attitudinal
cultural issue.
But in terms of
business strategy,
the single word is we
focus like a laser beam.
URBAN: Just when
you have questions,
if you could wait for
the microphone, then--
there are approximately 150 to
200 people outside this room.
GROVE: Yeah, I was going
to take two questions here.
URBAN: Why don't you just
have him get the microphone
so they can hear the
question outside.
And then we'll have some
questions from outside.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to ask you about China.
And I was wondering if you see
that as a strategic inflection
point with a number
of different things
still waiting to evolve
with the bids coming around
and trying to be a
little bit more definite.
What do you see as
the major challenges
in trying to decipher
when the noise of China
will become a true signal and
grow as much as everyone's
expecting it to?
GROVE: Do they hear
the question outside?
OK.
With the mic they do.
This is a very
complicated issue and I'm
going to try to maybe
oversimplify it a little bit.
But the brief answer to
your question is, yes I do.
I see China representing a major
change in the global business
environment.
Major change for the industries
and commerce in general.
Major change for the
information technology industry
and a major change for Intel.
And when you really think about
it goes a little bit more,
to go a little bit
more detail in that.
It is not merely that
it's 1.2 billion people.
It is their population, their
market size, their competence,
skill and educational level,
their ability to focus
is awesome.
The influence that
China as a country
has on Chinese nationals
all over the world.
The combination of that
is an economic force
that I think in 10
years time we're
going to look back and look
at what the exercise that we
have had visa vi Japan in
the '80s as a fire drill.
Outside question.
URBAN: Why don't you
take one more here.
GROVE: OK.
Who has the mic?
OK, we'll take that one.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: My question is about
the new paradigm in the client
server business.
In a client server
paradigm, you don't really
need a very powerful
microprocessor.
And also there is a trend to
move towards the lean client,
which doesn't
necessarily needs a lot
of powerful microprocessor, such
as the one offered by Intel.
My question is, how would
you prepare Intel to compete
in this kind of new paradigm?
Sort of transition, as you
say it, from one business
core to another?
GROVE: Now the problem
I have with questions
that state an assumption
as an embedded as part
of the question, is
that I don't know
how to answer it except as
a hypothetical situation.
I do not believe that client
server computer, computing,
does not require
powerful clients.
I believe the opposite.
I believe furthermore,
and the data
are plentiful on
this, that trends
in terms of general competition
of trends past, present,
or future, put more burden on
the clients rather than less
burden on the clients.
And just so I don't get
trapped in describing
a bigger plot or
a semi-log plot,
terminal emulation,
and network connected
pieces of today, and
network connected pieces
with a modern client server
application, for instance
the stuff that we are using
with distributed data entry
processes today where
most of the execution
takes place at the client.
But we can extrapolate that
and put in distributed objects
and the trend on a semi-log
plot to our client power
just continues on.
So it is the subject we
are fairly involved with,
but the upshot of it is that
I don't see a trend away
from that semi-log plot, which
is more power to the client
at all in the horizon.
However, let's take this,
suppose that was the case.
I would stand on a
soapbox and I would
get my buddy here and move them
into developing thin clients.
Because if trends go
to our thin clients,
I can delay those trends
but I can't change them.
And the implication
would probably
be that Intel's business
would be a lot less rich,
lower margin, et
cetera, et cetera.
All of those things.
But I would want to lead
in that lower margin
business the same way as I lead
in the higher margin business.
URBAN: We'll take
one from outside.
If Intel is focused
on microchips now,
what is your bubble of security
for the next inflection point
and how do you balance focus in
a bubble of other directions?
GROVE: Specifically, well you
can't question the written.
OK.
URBAN: If we had it two way
system, we could do this.
GROVE: I can't argue with
a written question here.
I can't question the
written question,
so let me tell you
my interpretation.
What is Intel's next strategic
focus going to be given--
URBAN: What's your next
inflection point as you see it?
GROVE: We set ourselves--
we kind of drove a
stake in the ground
in the early part of this
decade that the next evolution
and development of
computing is going to be,
I'm looking at Dean Urban as if
he had just asked a question,
is going to be communication
based applications
of computing.
And we started doing
exactly the kind of things
that we have talking about.
Amassing competencies in that.
And it wasn't very clear what
the communicating applications
were going to be.
The application vision
migrated around.
Our first ideas were email
embedded with rich multimedia
data types.
And then we went on from
that to video conferencing.
And then the internet arrived.
And what's common
in all of these,
they involve data
communications and they
involve rich data types, images,
sound, and video data elements.
Back to your point,
all of them requiring
a lot of high power
microprocessors at both
ends actually of the wire.
But what we have done in
this is we have plugged away
for probably five, six years
on bringing in expertise.
Because this was
not a natural skill
at a microprocessor company.
We had to hire people from
places like Bell Corps
and various other
communication [INAUDIBLE]
with the data communications
companies from colleges.
And we built up quite
an expertise in this.
And we continue to
push on that and we
look for developments
of businesses
that fit two criteria.
Use personal
computing and enhance
the use of personal computing
in communications applications.
And do so in such a way that
we can make a business out
of providing that
kind of application.
Yesterday we had a major
symposium in New York City that
was called Wired for
Management Initiative,
or an Intel symposium.
We filled the Madison Square
Garden conference center, not
the boxing arena.
Over 3,000 people came
up for a daylong set
of technical presentation
and demonstrations
whose element was basically
gelling all of these expertise
to deliver servicing of
client, computer clients,
from in a client server,
[? PCBS ?] client server
environment, through a
remote on the wire, down
the wire, management capability.
We have become, this is not
a gigantic business yet.
But I think it is
a decent business.
A growing business.
And a very important business
for letting the world
progress toward this notion
of communicating applications.
We are the world's leader in
management software, group
level management
software applications.
Not well-known, I mean
better known today
than it was yesterday.
But it is a result of that.
So, we are experimenting.
We are building our
core competencies.
And we have in fact moved
people along my little skit,
into that field who have
been very proficient leaders
in microprocessors.
So, will it all work?
Will it be significant?
Was our bet right?
We'll know that
in 10 years time.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
can you hear me?
GROVE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you think
that there might be
such thing as too
much control over an industry.
What I'm trying to
understand is that, you all
have a very big influence
over the industry
that you're working in.
And as such, you're controlling
a lot of the value chain.
And I'm wondering
is, in the long term,
if you feel responsible for more
than your particular company,
which is huge and
a lot of employees.
But I'm wondering
how you, if you,
feel responsible for the
company beyond, for the industry
beyond, your company.
And if so, what kind of
actions do you take to do that?
GROVE: A very
interesting question.
Let me start with, you kind of
segue through several questions
here, but let me try
with one of them.
What do we feel responsible for?
Which is a key question.
We have a very healthy share
of the microprocessor market.
One thing that's clear for us is
that we cannot grow a whole lot
more by increasing
that market share.
Some place in the last several
years, our corporate priority
has changed in a
very significant way
to growing the personal
computing industry.
Not growing our share of the
personal computing industry,
but undertaking
initiatives which
may or may not turn
into businesses.
The one I just described
being an example.
If it turns into a
business it's not
going to be a gigantic
business, but maybe it
won't turn into
a business but it
will grow the whole industry.
In that sense, we are working
on behalf of the entire industry
because our entire focus
is growth, growth, growth.
In the process of doing
that we have adopted
a certain set of internal
rules and regulations
which in the simplest form is
being extremely open about what
we do and not closing
up specifications,
except when it comes to the very
crown jewels of our company,
which is microprocessor design.
Other than that all
of our initiatives
are industry wide initiatives.
Now having said
that, let me tell you
who I feel the
biggest obligation to,
and that's consistent
with this drive.
I feel our biggest
obligation is not
to the members of the
industry, but to the members
of the larger community of
information technology users
who really determine
whether PCs are in
or PCs are out, or
think clients are
in or think clients are
out, whether PCs have
become boring or not boring.
We all have a very,
very strong user focus.
And we study user communities
in terms of consumers,
small businesses, large
businesses, internationally,
constantly.
We have various formal dialogues
with representative bodies
of them.
We merchandise to them.
And every once in a while
when we run into trouble we'll
find--
there's a Pentium
story, we end up
having to service them directly,
even though we didn't actually
sell anything to them.
So the answer to your
question, yes, we
feel responsible
for the industry.
Not because we are such good
guys, but because the only way
we can grow is if
the industry grows.
And the way we intend to
discharge this responsibility
is constant focus
on the evolving
needs or potential needs
of the user community.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You spoke earlier today about
complementary or complementors
as one of the six forces in
that five forces diagram.
And I think we all understand
how Microsoft fits in
with Intel and how that
complements Intel's business.
My question is, I'm curious
how your joint development
agreements with Hewlett-Packard,
how that's going to fit in.
And looking into the future how
Intel and Hewlett-Packard are
going to be able to
complement each other.
GROVE: I don't think that fits
the category of complimentor.
Not all business
relationships are
complementors in this sense of
two capabilities complementing
each other in the context
of the industry structure.
What we are doing
with Hewlett-Packard
is a business arrangement
where we got some technology
from them and they are going
to receive in various forms
that I'm not at liberty
to discuss payback
for that technology.
And out of that will
come another generation
of microprocessor.
The general extension of
our microprocessor line
to 64-bit width.
That is going to be an
industry standard product.
So this is more a
kind of a mixing
of two organizations genetic
pools, technically speaking.
And it's a quid pro
quo, an arrangement
between two companies.
When the dust settles,
Hewlett-Packard
will be a computer manufacturer
and will use Intel microchips
just like it does today.
Probably in a more
extensive fashion
as we transition to 64 bits.
And those
microprocessors will be
better for them and for
the rest of the industry
and for the users back in
the previous questions,
because they put that
technology in there.
Now, HP thought
about the technology
long before they put
that on the table.
And they realized that
technology's value is only
as good as the spread
of that technology
through the industry.
That they could not really
specialize and make it,
turn it into
commercial value given
that in the personal
computing area,
or in the computing
area altogether,
they have a relatively small
share of the total market.
So they made the
conscious decision
to adopt to this
horizontal open industry
model with their
technology through us.
And we become a distributor
of the particular part
of the technology that we
incorporate into our products
for the rest of the industry.
And then they negotiated
something in return for that.
So I don't think
it's going to change
the nature of the industry.
I think it is going
to however, result
in a better 64-bit
microprocessor generation
that we ourselves, just
with our own genetic pool,
could have been
able to generate.
URBAN: OK, last question.
This Is from an undergraduate.
Given what you know
now, what advice
would you give yourself in
1968 about running and building
Intel?
GROVE: On a personal
basis, I can comment.
On a corporate basis
I really can't.
Because I don't,
you know you got
to put this into perspective.
I was 32 years old
when I went to Intel.
I was a research engineer.
I never went near a
production, had never
gone near a production
line and the like.
My biggest worry
when I went to Intel
was I really didn't know how
I'm going to earn my keep.
And I mean this in
all seriousness.
So I adapted to the situation.
I did OK.
But I think in the early
stages I was somewhat
hampered by this question, what
is a research guy like me going
to do in a commercial startup?
So I don't know if
that's a general advice
or general problem
or general advice,
but to myself, I would
say don't worry about it.
It's going to work out OK.
It did.
As to how Intel could have done
better in those early days,
we started out extremely well.
We hit recessions and
various bumps and grinds.
But strategically, we
focused on one thing, which
was semiconductor memories.
We started much in the
same kind of hedged
our technological bets
and went for a while
in three different directions.
We jettisoned one pretty early.
Jettisoned the
second one after we
saw that MOS memories worked.
Jettisoned bipolar
memories a few years later.
So, with the first few
years strategically
I can't see, even in retrospect,
what we could have done better.
Later, we started getting
trapped, which is a big lesson.
Getting trapped in our own
success and our own legacy.
And were slower to
change with opportunities
and responding to the
threats than we might have.
But that's what this
whole thing was about.
So thank you very
much for coming
and thanks for your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
URBAN: Just as a
final announcement.
Dr. Grove's book is
actually on sale outside.
And since my background
is marketing,
he promised me a Commission
for every book you sell.
It's the greatest
book you'll ever get.
And our next lecture
will be on December 3rd.
Mr. DeSimone, who is the
CEO of 3M corporation.
So continuing a
great tradition here.